although 2020 brought much of the sports
world to a halt
sapping billions of dollars from leagues
around the world the best of the best
still pulled in the big bucks the 10
highest paid athletes in the world took
home
pre-tax gross earnings of 1.05 billion
dollars over the past 12
months that's 28 more than last year's
top earners
the combined haul falls just short of
the 1.06 billion dollar record set in
2018.
that was the 12-month window in which
boxer floyd mayweather earned 285
million dollars
almost all from his 2017 pay-per-view
fight with conor mcgregor
this year mcgregor comes out on top
having leveraged his massive popularity
in mixed martial arts to build a
lucrative hustle outside ufc's octagon
mcgregor pulled in 180 million dollars
most of it from his recent sale of his
majority stake in whiskey brand
proper number 12 to proximo spirits for
150 million dollars
we are not here to take part we are here
to take over
three other athletes also surpassed 100
million dollars in total earnings this
year
soccer stars lionel messi and cristiano
ronaldo and nfl quarterback dak prescott
messi set a record for soccer players
with his 2021 total of 130 million
dollars
this comes after a summer of
off-the-pitch drama with fc barcelona
followed by reports of the club's dire
financial state and the revelation that
messi's contract was worth 670
million dollars over an american
football dak prescott made 107.5 million
dollars
the cowboys quarterback broke the record
for nfl players thanks to a 66 million
dollar signing bonus from america's team
this year's top four join only five
other athletes to have made more than
100 million dollars in a single year
the other members of this prestigious
club roger federer
floyd mayweather neymar manny pacquiao
and tiger
woods lebron james was just shy
of joining that elite group the los
angeles lakers star took home 96.5
million dollars
a record for nba players and this year's
top athletes
also thrived outside of their respective
sports they made a combined 512 million
dollars off the field
crushing the previous record of 407.5
million dollars from 2020
you